ah
[Música]
a
en argentina la vacuna contra el cubil
19 será gratuita de distribución estatal
y no obligatoria el gobierno espera
poder vacunar a 13 millones de personas
un cuarto de la población entre enero y
marzo de 2021 se priorizará algunos
grupos como el personal de salud fuerzas
de seguridad y mayores de 60 años
el desafío logístico de inmunizar a la
población es tal que hay quienes dudan
de la capacidad del gobierno para poder
llevarlo adelante
en cualquier caso argentina está
avanzando en varios frentes para la
provisión de las vacunas el presidente
alberto fernández dijo que espera que se
puede inocular a 10 millones de personas
entre enero y febrero con la vacuna rusa
sputnik también anunció que en marzo es
posible que lleguen dosis de las vacunas
de astrazéneca y oxford de facer y vayan
tec y de las del mecanismo kóvacs de la
organización mundial de la salud de
acuerdo con el presupuesto 2021 y
disponible el equivalente a cerca de 170
millones de dólares para la compra de
vacunas aunque es posible que se
terminen destinando más recursos para
tal fin
[Música]
la pasada semana se conoció que el
gobierno colombiano había firmado una
resolución para la compra de 10 millones
de dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
por valor de 123 millones de dólares una
compra de la vacuna a la farmacéutica
pfiezer biotech que servirá para cubrir
a 5 millones de colombianos la
estrategia consistirá en vacunar desde
marzo a trabajadores de la salud
personas mayores de 60 años y aquellos
que tengan comorbilidades el problema es
que no habrá vacunas para todos esos
colectivos puesto que se estima que son
14 millones de personas el resto del
colectivo de riesgo se espera que sean
vacunados con nuevas compras o bien con
kóvacs un mecanismo subscrito por 188
países para una distribución justa e
igualitaria de la vacuna una vacuna que
el senado aprobó que sea gratuita para
todos los colombianos tal y como anunció
el presidente iván duque sin embargo la
gestión del gobierno también tiene
críticas el congresista josé daniel
lópez del partido cambio radical
denunció que colombia va a acceder a las
vacunas tarde y con sobrecostes
[Música]
la vacunación contra el kobe 19
comenzará en méxico tan pronto como este
mismo mes según anunció el canciller
marcelo ebrard al dar a conocer en días
recientes que el reino unido- autorizó
ya la vacuna de facer que eeuu está
pronto a darle su aval por lo que méxico
comenzaría con este proceso en diciembre
se tiene un convenio de compra firmado
con fisher por lo que se espera que
antes de fin de año llegue un lote con
las primeras 250.000 dosis por lo menos
el gobierno tiene un acuerdo de
precompra también con los laboratorios
cancino y astrazéneca en el caso de
cancino se encuentra ya desarrollando
estudios clínicos de fase 3 a unos 15
mil voluntarios el gobierno tiene
destinados un millón setecientos mil
dólares para comprar vacunas para 116
millones de mexicanos la oposición
cuestiona que hay poca claridad en la
adquisición del fármaco y el presidente
dijo que será este martes 8 de diciembre
cuando se den a conocer todos los
detalles del plan de vacunación aunque
adelantó que las fuerzas armadas
ayudaran a distribuir el fármaco y que
la autoridad regulatoria mexicana
eliminará trabas burocráticas
[Música]